[Musique]
stéphanie bonjour très heureux de vous
retrouver depuis washington alors j -1
avant l'élection dernière ligne droite
pour les deux candidats et c'est
évidemment le marathon pour recueillir
les derniers votes des électeurs mais
bonjour olivier évidemment un vrai
marathon vous vous en doutez commençons
par donald trump il enchaîne aujourd'hui
pas moins de cinq meetings dans quatre
états différents caroline du nord
pennsylvanie michigan wisconsin avec un
dernier stop grogne rapids au michigan
c'est la barre précisément qu'il avait
créé la surprise en 2016 en raflant ce
fief traditionnellement acquis aux
démocrates tous ses états en tout cas
ont un point commun celui d'être des
états clés ces fameux swing states dans
lequel se joue véritablement l'élection
joe boyd a lui aussi se concentre bien
évidemment sur ses états clés est sans
doute le plus important d'entre eux avec
la floride jdir et la pennsylvanie où il
est d'ailleurs née joe biden celui qui
l'emportent dans cet état de
pennsylvanie gagne 20 grands électeurs
c'est la pennsylvanie qui avait fait
basculer l'élection en 2016 la
pennsylvanie d'ailleurs qui a élu 20 des
27 5 derniers présidents américains
c'est vous dire à quel point cet état
est majeur et joe biden en a bien
conscience écouter lors d'un meeting
justement hier chaque jour chaque jour
est un nouveau rappel de l'importance
des enjeux de jusqu'où ira l'autre camp
pour tenter de supprimer la
participation surtout ici à philadelphie
le président trump a très peur de ce qui
va se passer en pennsylvanie il sait que
les habitants de pennsylvanie ont leur
mot à dire
si vous avez votre mot à dire il sait
qu'il n'a aucune chance
mais pourquoi est ce si important
justement la pennsylvanie et bien on l'a
entendu un joe biden en direct de
philadelphie il ya aussi peur qui est
très acquis aux démocrates mais l'état
est tout de même assez divisés puisque
le reste de l'état de pennsylvanie est
plutôt rurale et et blanc si j'ose dire
donc d'où l'importance caille que joe
biden à y rechercher des voies là-bas
joe biden qui a pu compter aujourd'hui
également sur le soutien de barack obama
en meeting pour joe biden en géorgie et
en floride
autre état clé majeure puisque celui qui
l'emportera là-bas remportera 29 grands
électeurs au lycée alors stéphanie sous
nous sommes donc à la veille de
l'élection et il y a plus de doute sur
le fait qu'on puisse connaître le nom du
vainqueur dès le 4 novembre au matin
il ya de plus en plus de doutes en rien
n'est moins sûr pour annoncer le
vainqueur il faut être en mesure de
savoir si l'un des candidats atteint
vous savez la barre des 2 170 grands
électeurs sur 538 grands électeurs mais
la pandémie là aussi est venu
bouleverser cette élection puisque
les électeurs ont été exhortés utiliser
le vote anticipé et le vote par
correspondance ici bat des records je
vais vous donner quelques chiffres les
derniers plus de 95 millions 500 mille
américains ont déjà voté pour cette
élection présidentielle qui se tiendra
demain dont 62 millions 200 mille juste
par correspondance c'est l'équivalent de
70 % de la totalité des votes de 2016
sauf que chaque état a ses règles pour
dépouiller en ces fameux bulle d'un
bulletin de vote certains ont déjà
commencé d'autres comme justement la
fameuse pennsylvanie où le wisconsin
vont le faire le jour j ça veut dire que
ça peut prendre du temps bien évidemment
on s'en doute ce qui crée l'inquiétude
des observateurs mais et surtout aussi
du camp républicain qui voit là une
manière de faire des fraudes écouter
donald trump qui a mis en garde
je pense que c'est terrible quand les
butins ne peuvent pas être collectées
après une élection
je pense que c'est terrible quand des
personnes ou des états peuvent prendre
beaucoup de temps après que les
élections soient terminés pour compiler
les votes parce que ça ne peut mener
qu'à une chose et c'est très mauvais
vous savez à quoi ça peut mener
je pense que c'est une chose très
dangereuse terrible je pense qu'il
pourrait y avoir beaucoup de fraude et
d'abus
je pense que la cour suprême a pris une
terrible décision une terrible décision
mais je ne sais pas si ça va changer
parce qu'on va arriver à la nuit dès que
les élections sont finies
nous avocats entrent en jeu et on le
comprend en écoutant d'olonne de rome
c'est justement là que le bât blesse si
les résultats sont serrés notamment
toujours dans cette fameuse pennsylvanie
où par exemple dans le michigan et bien
le camp républicain déjà dense et déjà
annoncé qu'ils allaient contester en
justice
cette élection et demandé le recomptage
des voix s'étaient déjà arrivé je sais
pas si vous vous en souvenez à l'époque
à c'était à l'époque de al gore et bush
en floride
finalement al gore avait décidé de ne
pas contester et george bush avait ainsi
remporté la présidentielle d'à peine
quelques centaines de voix d'écart
merci beaucoup stéphanie pour toutes ces
précisions merci nous faire vivre au
plus près du terrain cette campagne et
on se retrouve demain pour le jour j
avec une édition spéciale avant les
résultats à suivre en direct sur rt
france